you're in this movie and who's in it
with you Oprah Winfrey yeah did your mom
you know did you take her on the set of
Selma did she meet Oprah I actually took
my mother to Oprah's home but I had to
threaten her first I had to say mother
do not I had to speak through my teeth
and say if you embarrass me
don't ask in me don't say anything don't
have the stories what would she say to
Oprah that would be embarrassing
seriously say anything I was only gonna
ask her what's going on with her instead
no no no now you did get to socialize
with Oprah and you have you shot
something with Oprah right this is yeah
I've been on your Instagram yes I've
been on your Instagram and you this is
you and Oprah it looks like what are you
doing you're cleaning up in the kitchen
we are washing dishes this after a party
because you looks like you guys are
having a lot of fun for cleaning well
here's what I will tell you I out was
lovely
yeah she's everything you think she is
yeah however she has a very heavy hand
when it comes to pouring a drink you
really oh yeah so she likes a big strong
drink she gives you about 98% alcohol
and then a DNA sample of a mixer this is
this is some home video of you guys just
after a party having a good time let's
roll that
a lot of
you